ramp prices have been really high for
quite a while now but was an action
necessary like we thought
[Music]
welcome to Horus hobbies so as you guys
already know there's been a lot more
demand on the DRAM market because of
smartphones cars new gamers and the
rising popularity of SSDs which also use
NAND flash this sudden hike in demand
was not able to be met by the suppliers
and as a result it led to really high
Ram prices that we receiving currently
and it doesn't help that some
manufacturers like micron are actually
in the process of going to lower
nanometer processes like from 20 meters
to 20 meters plus ddr5 Ram is going to
be coming out relatively soon like
within the next two years so it doesn't
make sense for these Ram companies to
invest in more ddr4 production
facilities when they're going to have to
change it in the imminent future until
now it was expected that the current
pricing situation was a result of price
fixing price fixing is when dominating
companies get together and create
artificially low supply so that price
exponentially rise when demand rises as
well there were even many possible
lawsuits who considering this matter but
now it seems as if these companies are
just charging more just because they can
first of all a Korean based digital
Times report is suggesting that the
market peak for ddr4 Ram will be the end
of 2018
however asking high necks and Samsung
are suggesting that they're going to be
continuing to ramp up production so
market demand should be met at the
beginning of 2019 finally on top of this
there seems to be a new manufacturer
called in Auckland
who's play to start mass production of
ddr4 Ram at the beginning of 2019 so
starting 2019 we should be seeing much
better Ram prices now getting back to
curb ramp pricing situations while
unfortunately it may have all been
unnecessary and it may just be the
workings of these greedy companies for
example right now microns
operating margins are up to 50% before
this huge price increase at the end of
2016 there
operating margins was only 20% that's a
huge difference based on current market
prices it is natural that we expect that
it is costing more for these rare
producers to produce rare because of the
high stress put on certain RAM
components like NAND flash but based on
these margins
it doesn't seem the cost to produce RAM
has increased at all and that these
companies are just charging more because
they can and when you really think about
it
it is actually our fault for these high
prices because it's our willingness to
overpay for him that has led the
situation to get so out of hand at the
same time a lot of us really needed RAM
and we couldn't just keep waiting for
RAM prices to drop so it's really
deceptive of these companies to take
advantage of this need so that's really
the truth behind the current Ram pricing
situation more demand and other supply
definitely plays a part of it but it
really comes down to these companies
taking advantage of our willingness to
overpay for RAM because we need it so
that is really unfortunate but moving
forward what should we do well the
holiday season is just around the corner
and there should be some great Ram Joe's
coming out then so that should
definitely make it much more affordable
for a lot of you guys also there is
going to be excess supply of started
2019 so we should be seeing a huge price
drop coming very soon and what about
ddr5 rim did you wait for that well
given the current demand for ddr4 Ram
and companies are still ramping up
production for ddr4 Ram it's definitely
going to be taking a while for dr v ram
pickup even if it does get finalized
this year so really we probably won't be
seeing it till 2020 so it is still quite
a while out so the good news is that Ram
prices situation is going to get a lot
better very soon and the bad news
is that so far Ram companies have been
taking advantage of our needs so how do
you guys feel about this are you guys
angry that these companies have been so
deceptive or are you just happy that you
got it right before this huge price
increase make sure to comment down below
what you guys think because I do it all
my comments I'm curious as to what you
guys think to make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like spew then
make sure to drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until next
time this is Hari and I'll see you guys
on the next one